[Musique]
les moyens de faire bouger le ballon sur
mon douala en post prod
[Musique]
je vais rencontrer la future élite du
tango bourges basket un club de basket
qui a été fondée en 1967 et qui joue
avec son équipe féminine au plus haut
niveau du championnat de france ces
futures championnes pour me donner
quelques astuces afin d'atteindre le
sommet devenir pros comme leur en sommes
aux gamines ici tu veux venir programme
dit pour qui mettre le maillot j'ai un
maillot et tout numéro 3 dambach free
bon on va commencer par stella à partir
de quel âge tu as senti que tu avais un
truc en plus pour espérer atteindre le
sommet j'ai commencé le basket vraiment
pour du loisir et ainsi je dirais quand
j'avais 13 ans je me suis dit que je
pouvais peut-être faire entre jasmin de
mesure combien un mètre 93 à 4 ans elle
mesurait déjà un mètre
quatre-vingt-treize son destin était
déjà prêt écrit que veux tu vous êtes
comme mon terminal à la fin de l'année
et le bac donc s'il entend encore parler
des mauvaises notes je vais techique ont
été en dessous de 16 mois sur 20 je
viens et où j'ai tâché
alors comment on fait pour gérer
justement les études et le haut niveau
il faut vraiment avoir envie faut être
concentré savoir gérer son temps comment
elle est étalée l'entraînement d'une
future pro au minimum une fois par jour
et une fois dans la semaine on adore le
matin et le soir aussi j'ai beaucoup
joué au basket donc je suis prêt à
m'entraîner un petit peu avec vous
montrer quelque chose de voir mon tir à
trois points
[Musique]
dit à ma mère que je l'aimé très fort
très
épuré fait de
se passer peut-être dans le banc vous
parce que j'ai pas compris
personnellement j'ai pas compris elle
était devant et puis d'un seul coup elle
était en train de c'est normal chez vous
c'est la vie de tous les jours ok
d'accord ça les fait marrer en plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à d'autres le coach 28 ans de présence
ici comment on fait pour repérer dire à
l'huile à 8 ans il va être très fort et
comme la taille c'est quand même
important parce qu est la taille n'est
pas le plus important tu abuses d'ela et
jesse l'est de mombasa créer ses
démineurs sont quand même des
obligations scolaires et tous comment on
fait pour s'adapter le discours tout ça
alors déjà dans la détection on
surveille leurs capacités
intellectuelles etc on a manu par
exemple qui nous a écrit un beau livre
jeanne emmanuelle ces jeunes là tu
l'écris qui lâche le livre est gelée
commencé à 15 ans à peu près et j'ai
terminé pendant le premier confinement
de migrants le monde sait tout faire
quoi parce que deux professionnels
littérature et ou machin tu envie de
présenter mon émission
sait tout faire ouais je laisse
entraîner parce que sinon le coach et
moi ces yeux là qu'il commence à virer
les vagues ou c'est
[Musique]
mon défi c'est un autre sport que je
maîtrise c'est la boxe non mais tu
as bossé dur
merci
alors c'est quoi le plus important un
lagarde
s'était mis en garde ce que j'appelle le
temps de finir ma phrase bien sûr ça va
mais ça bizarre là on va geler si je
crois
à une bonne boîte à thé bon
on est solide on n'est pas solides